[Música]
la moda que es fácilmente revolucionaria
en cuanto a propuestas artísticas suele
serlo mucho menos cuando se trata de
cuestiones sociales ha tenido que morir
un diseñador negro de cáncer a los 41
años para que la gente se dé cuenta de
que la lucha por la igualdad está lejos
de haber terminado virtual hablo era un
ícono porque nacido en illinois en eeuu
en 1980 se graduó con honores e
ingeniería civil y arquitectura pero en
la década de 2000 se dedicó a la música
viste y asesora entre otros a la
estrella del rap kanye west virginia
blue decidió entonces crear su propia
marca de ropa de calle y fue
dirigida blow es un diseñador que
representa el éxito del orgullo porque
es uno de los pocos que podría estar en
una casa grande dancing ghost mesón en
2018 el bm se fijó en su espíritu
visionario y le confió la dirección de
las colecciones masculinas del wii
brutón se convirtió en el primer
diseñador negro que introdujo la
diversidad en el mundo del lujo virgil
habló era y con la rabia de malcom x la
serenidad de martin luther king es por
fin la fase de talón es esperanza es
fuerza es talento y la energía es áfrica
expresándose es juventud es todo es
modernidad
si sea un grupo de la murga dj y maneja
y si el primer y único diseñador de moda
en negro avalado por la federación
francesa de alta costura en moda insiste
en que muchos africanos de la diáspora
como barry la bleu se ven privados de su
cultura al crecer
para el creo que fue político por
supuesto para la diversidad la
existencia de personas negras en la
industria del lujo creo que lo
reivindico su lado americano negro
americano y su lado africano también
porque es de origen ghanés que era
importante que se reivindicará que
mostrara ese lado negro así que es la
diversidad la que gana ahora esperamos a
ver a quien vi tumba jaja
a quién va a seleccionar vuitton podemos
imaginar que van a utilizar de nuevo un
diseñador negro no lo creo sería
demasiado de entrada tal vez pero
dejaremos que hagan la libre elección
sería gracioso que volvieran a poner
negro y también sería sorprendente
beauty lab lo ha dejado su huella en
toda una generación de diseñadores afro
en todo el mundo así que por qué no
quién es y se vive y trabaja en lagos en
nigeria cada vez que viene a parís a
presentar sus colecciones no oculta su
emoción por poder expresarse por fin
libremente
sé que oportunidades como ésta no sería
oportunidades pero espacios como este no
han sido realmente frecuentados por
gente como yo y es un nuevo amanecer
para mi sabes siento que puedo siento
que aquí puedo hacer cualquier cosa y la
gente como yo debería sentirse como se
siente esta noche es un nuevo amanecer
para mí y sabes es un nuevo amanecer
para unirse la moda comprometida permite
liberar los cuerpos así como la palabra
[Música]
familia es not allowed
soy queer en nigeria no está permitido
ser juicio es imposible por ejemplo
porque no puedo pedirle a un chico que
se maquilla la cara en lagos de donde
vengo porque no puedo pedirle a un tipo
que se pinte las uñas
porque la policía me detendrá y me
preguntará por qué me pinto las uñas
tengo una razón para mostrar mi
colección aquí en parís
y esta razón es un mensaje para la gente
de mi país es como escribirles una carta
y quiero que la gente que se supone que
cuida de nosotros el presidente la
policía vean esto y empiecen a pensar de
una manera nueva y diferente
otra figura negra destacada del
continente africano es de bbva google
con sede en johannesburgo quiere ser
sabio y positivo gracias a la pobre su
familia a la que brinde homenaje y
recurriendo a los archivos fotográficos
familiares de los años 60 a los 80 para
su colección de verano 2022
siento que en este momento especialmente
en sudáfrica ha habido mucha agitación
social ya sabes
y quería tener un estado de ánimo más
positivo y siempre que lo hago pienso en
mi familia
así que el optimismo y la alegría lo que
quería explorar esta temporada se salde
ahora cjex poder de descenso pero es
cuadren en chester así que es un
proyecto muy interesante porque mi
familia y yo mi madre y mi tía nos
reunimos y sacamos una caja de viejas
fotos familiares
y fue muy interesante ver cómo volvían a
la vida estos recuerdos y quería que
cada mirada bueno cada foto familiar
estuviera representada en la colección
así que me inspiré en estas fotos
familiares
cada luz que está inspirado en el
original que llevaba a mi madre mi tía o
mi abuela y siempre siento que la
familia ha sido una parte muy importante
de mi inspiración
es
realmente emocionante ya sabes
inspirarse y ver estas cosas en una
revista y ver cómo puede transformarnos
con los recursos limitados que tenemos
diablos solía decir el obstáculo es que
me cuesta verme como diseñador porque
los diseñadores no se parecen a mí puede
que ya no sea totalmente cierto